can we teach that kind of leadership is
a good question i have always tried to
do that i mean a part of my job as
creative director has always been to
nurture other creative people towards
that end I try to we always try to
create new creative directors and not
all creative people are creative
director material you you actually have
to have two sides of your brain you
can't just have your right side
functioning you have to have a little
bit of your left side and they have to
kind of talk to each other otherwise you
can't be a creative director but I think
you can teach them to do that if they
have an inherent desire to have that
kind of role but I always say you know
don't go that don't go down that path
unless you really want to because
there's no turning back once you start
to be the leader no
you